it's great to welcome back to the
program by audience requests dr. Aubrey
de Grey the chief science officer of the
Sens Research Foundation which is a
biomedical research charity that
develops new therapies to combat aging
so let's start there I first became
aware of your work back in 2005 when you
were featured in 60 minutes and we've
spoken about the broad and narrower
focus of your work a number of times how
would you characterize the progress
that's been made since that 60 minutes
piece in 2005 in the areas you work on
it's been pretty good I mean for anyone
I guess working at the cutting edge of
any pioneering technology there's always
a kind of you know double edge to it you
always have you know pride about how
much progress has been made but at the
same time you always wish it could have
been even more but yeah I mean think
about okay the what the Sens Research
Foundation has done in the past decade
has really you know we've broken through
a number of really formidable barriers
that were completely you know stalling
research in various areas so that now
even the most difficult areas of sense
are seeing great rapid progress and
that's enormously heartening also one
thing that really makes a huge impact
for us and we hope will continue to do
so is that a number of our project over
the past couple of years especially have
reached a sufficient level of proof of
concept that we've been able to spin
them out into startup companies in one
way or another and of course there's a
huge number of people out there who are
you know visionary and you know they
want to invest in high-risk high-reward
activities but they don't want to donate
so they have been difficult for us to
gain access to as a non-profit but know
that we can offer true investment
opportunities that opens up a whole new
source of lending so yeah I think
something's definitely moving forward
and of course it also applies to work
with other people have been doing
independently of us so there are now
very well known things that have
happened in the past decade like the
development job induced pluripotent stem
cells is about CRISPR between editing
and such lag and there are also a number
of much less well-known things which are
still very important that have allowed
these bellarius to move forward so of
course well let's look a cancer for
example the whole field of cancer
immunotherapy which was really you know
seeing very little progress over 20
years until a few years ago is now
completely exploded and everyone's
working on it now and we have close
links with a number of the most
cutting-edge leading companies that are
working in that even though it's not
actually resulting from our own work so
yeah I mean it once really got to be
pretty happy about where things standing
right now the layperson might look at
for the sake of sticking with this 2005
day just the last 12 or so years one
might look at life expectancy in 2005
and compare it to life expectancy for
someone born in 2017 and see that while
there's been a modest improvement it is
after all sort of sort of modest is that
even a good indicator as to the progress
of the type of work that you're doing
not remotely it's absolutely unrelated
the work that we're doing is early-stage
biomedical research which has not yet
got anywhere near even reaching clinical
trials and of course when it does reach
clinical trials has been another feather
you know long period while the tests are
really done before the thing actually
reaches the wider world and becomes
something that doctors can actually use
and even then we would not expect to see
any impact on the statistics that you're
talking about on the demographics of
life expectancy for quite a few years
after that until they impacted least
therapies has actually been felt across
the world or across the country
in terms of widespread adoption so yeah
absolutely irrelevant it is interesting
to look of course at what is driving the
increase in life expectancy that we're
seeing and most people think that at
this point the main driver is the same
one that it has been for the past
several decades really namely the
improved prosperity that various web
that all developed countries really were
able to see a hundred years ago or there
abouts during the first half of the 20th
century the life expectancy was of
course rising pretty rapidly because we
were seeing progressively more universal
access to simple medicines that and
hygiene and so on that would prevent
early death in infancy or in childbirth
or whatever but at the same time is that
we were also seeing better nutrition and
it turns out that nutrition very early
in life even prenatal nutrition is a
really important contributor to lifelong
health including life expectancy of
course so there's a widespread agreement
now that this is probably the number one
contributor that people who were born
let's say 80 years ago just were on
average born in a more prosperous
environment in Natal USA than people who
were born let's say 10 or 20 or 30 years
earlier now the bad news is that that is
probably reaching diminishing returns
now most of the the impact of increased
prosperity that has been the driver of
basics was pretty much done by 80 years
ago so what that would predict is that
over the next 10 or 20 years we probably
will see a leveling or the slowing down
of the increase in life expectancy and
indeed oh I don't know if you're
familiar with the book by Angus Deaton
where he writes about this the Nobel
Prize winner Angus Deaton he talks quite
a bit about how you know the early early
20th century saw drastic increases in
life expectancy in more developed
countries mostly as a result of reduced
infant mortality in other words if you
save people who have many years left to
live that will impact life expectancy
much more drastically than cancer
treatments that might extend someone's
life for a few years and then in the in
the second half of the 20th century we
saw that reduction in infant mortality
spread more to the developing world and
this seems to be a bit of a ceiling
we're approaching is it not so um think
of it as a kind of soft ceiling
so yes the the reduction in mortality
that was early mortality caused by
infections was pretty much over by World
War two in the developed world and in
fact it's reaching a kind of feeling
even in most of the developing world now
if you look at worldwide statistics it
turns out that overall life expectancy
across the whole world are together if
now something like 71 so in other words
it's less than one decade short of where
the developed world is and the largest
countries in the world are of course the
major contributors to that so we're
talking you know China India Brazil
Indonesia Pakistan Bangladesh these
countries are all motoring up and and
there's not much more to do now the
second wave of life expectancy increase
that I mentioned that's caused by
improved
early life nutrition and such like that
too is beginning to reach diminishing
returns in the developed world and I
think it's going to you know beast who
continued to be a major contributor in
the in the in these very large countries
in the developing world for a little
while longer but yeah any any
contributor to increased longevity
eventually hit diminishing returns and
you need some new things to do better
and so of course the new thing that's
coming next but it won't be with us for
maybe 20 years from now is the kind of
work that trans Research Foundation does
the regenerative medicine the
rejuvenation technologies that will
repair the damage of aging and keep it
useful to go through some of the
different areas in which one
one could focus this type of work you
and I have spoken about a diet of
related factors we've we've spoken a
little bit about stem-cell research you
mentioned the CRISPR project is there
one particular Avenue that you believe
has the most promise in the work you're
doing no there is not I think it's very
important to understand that even though
our approach of repairing damage
eliminates a huge majority of the
complexity of the problem that the
complexity of Aging the complexity of
metabolism and pathologies nevertheless
it's still pretty complicated so this
needs to be viewed very much as a divide
and conquer approach in which we
compartmentalize the various types of
damage of Aging we classify them into a
manageable number of categories we
always talk about seven categories and
each of those categories has a
corresponding damage repair paradigm the
damage repair approach that we are
developing and other people are
developing but the key thing to take
into account is that any one of those
seven types of damage is perfectly
capable of killing us all on schedule
more or less you know however well would
fix all the other six so we can it would
be a very bad idea to impose some kind
of ranking of importance we do have a
ranking of properties for ourselves in
terms of where we put our money in
funding research but that ranking is
dictated by the necessity to not have a
ranking in other words the things that
we do prioritize are simply the things
that other people are working on more
effectively and where we would make less
of a difference and we prioritize other
things that are most neglected by other
researchers where are you currently on
caloric restriction I recently read
about a study I believe it was a twenty
year or two decades study looking at
caloric restriction in monkeys and that
particular study said its results show
that there was no longevity increase in
the monkeys who are on a calorically
restricted diet what's your sense of
that study and caloric restriction in
general right
so there were actually two studies
happening in parallel both in the USA on
monkey calorie restriction and they both
reported their results around the same
time a few years ago now one of them
reported no increase as you say the
other one reported us a small increase
in longevity we look yeah more closely
at the data the two studies were not
really in contradiction to each other
because the details of how the studies
were done seemed to indicate that the
arm the truth is somewhere in between
that the probably wasn't in the body can
be an increase from lifelong calorie
restriction in monkeys it's very small
maybe a few percent in terms of the
increase in longevity now this to me was
no surprise whatsoever of course it's a
much smaller increase than what you see
in shorter lived species if you go down
the list of calorie restriction studies
in terms of species on whom it has been
tried the next longest lived is
Labradors drugs that normally live about
11 years and actually Purina funded a
study of calorie restriction in
Labradors sometime ago in which they go
roughly 10% increasing lifespan in mice
you can get to a 40 or 50 percent
depending on what do the same for rats
with invested animals of course live a
couple of years normally if you go down
the evolutionary chain further and you
look at you know fruit flies or
nematodes
you can get several fold increasing if
you do this kind of thing just right and
of course the same applies in all of
these species if rather than doing
calorie restriction itself you kind of
emulate calories that can be kind of
trick the body into thinking within a
fan in when it isn't by manipulating the
genetics the genes of the animals or in
some cases by pharmacological means
drugs like rapamycin for example but the
reason I said it's not surprise is
because this inverse correlation that we
see where longer live species get less
of a benefit from calorie restriction
this is something that not only have
been said
for a very long time prior to this
monkey study but also it's predicted by
evolutionary theory if we just remember
that long famines in the wild in nature
are not so frequent as for Italians then
that immediately predicts that the
selective advantage the selective
pressure that a species would experience
to have machinery that would respond to
famine by shifting metabolic priorities
in a way that extends life you know that
that pressure will be weak set in long
live species so it's all very much what
I would have expected and the
disappointing thing is that a large
number of very distinguished and smarts
gerontologist basically totally ignored
this for using your gears they've
basically just swept this look under the
carpet and carried on studying calorie
restriction as if it were the holy grail
of life extension when it was no weight
ever could be let's pick up our
conversation there we'll continue
tomorrow with dr. Aubrey de Grey we're
continuing our conversation with dr.
Aubrey de Grey chief science officer of
Sens Research Foundation we spoke
yesterday about some of the latest
science that you've been working on in
different areas of study if you google
your name you will see that there are
many many people interested in talking
about what they say would be the
disastrous social cultural and economic
implications of as you say curing aging
just to pick one place to start with
some of those criticisms let's talk
about overpopulation or population of
our planet on the one hand we know that
physically there is so much empty space
on our planet and that the the sort of
carrying capacity space-wise is orders
of magnitude beyond the current
population of our planet at the same
time the population we do have on our
planet has managed to do some pretty
significant damage to the climate at
pollution etc so what is your general
perspective on the criticism that the
planet would not be able to handle the
damage done if we were to indefinitely
extend human lifespans
it frustrates me a great deal that these
questions are so persistent that people
continue to raise these specters you
know as if they were problems that
nobody had ever thought of before
because the fact is I and of course many
other people have been giving answers to
these concerns for a very long time and
nobody comes back and says this answer
is invalid but they feel that reason
they just you know go quiet and go away
and then the following day they've got
the same concern as if I hadn't actually
given any answer at all so now first of
all let me yet again repeat the actual
answer to your question and then let me
discuss briefly why people why I believe
people have this cognitive dissonance
yeah the answer of course is very much
heralded by the way that you put the
question it's all about the carrying
capacity of the planet as defined not by
the physical space that the planet has
to offer but rather by the level of
damage the level of pollution that the
average person inflicts on the planet so
if we take the most conspicuous example
which is of course climate change we
know that ultimately climate change
arises from anthropogenic action in
particular from the extensive use of
fossil fuels as well as the various
aspects of agriculture and the main
reason why there's no reason to worry
about overpopulation in the future
is because of other technologies that
are coming along to address those
problems such as for example you know
cheaper solar energy and other renewable
sources of energy also good artificial
meat which quite clearly going to
actually be perfectly tasty as well as
having much less environmental footprint
one can look at other technologies that
are slightly more distantly related with
this or to have an impact like for
example desalination which is becoming
much more efficient you know all these
things will add up to a grass stick
reduction
in the overall environmental impact that
the average person has and that
translates directly into an increase a
corresponding increase in the carrying
capacity to the planet number of people
that the planet can support without an
unacceptable level of environmental
impact I think the one is the one area
though where I would say it's important
to think about how that would happen in
practice I mean that what you're saying
is of course not wrong the the question
I have is that much of how our society
is organized around energy consumption
and the other areas you mentioned much
of that is driven by corporate interests
and so the question I would have is if
we were able to make great progress on
curing aging to use the term that that
you apply to the problem there is no
direct link between oh people are living
way longer so now we will implement
these technologies there will be
significant resistance from the major
corporations that stand to make money
from the from the status quo and they're
not really going to care about you
solving Aging in a sense you're
absolutely right about that it's a bit
it were a case of relying on society
reacting to the problem by reducing a
level of pollution then yes I would be
cautious I would be quite scared that
would is that very best be a substantial
lag time between the top of the problem
getting worse and the problem being
solved but however luckily we don't need
to appeal to that kind of logic the
curse the fact is these technologies are
coming reasons already solar energy for
example is becoming more prevalent not
because we need to address climate
change but simply because the underlying
technologies that the letter solar
energy are becoming cheaper and it's
possible for people to make serious
money by actually supplying energy
supplying electricity and suchlike now
will the numbers of cents per kilowatt
hour then can be achieved from fossil
fuels so it's going to be purely
mercenary economics that actually leads
us into this cleaner world and we don't
need to worry about any kind of
humanitarian imperative so let me
actually now accept it
and tell you why I think this problem of
the concerns that people have remains so
prevalent yeah but this is really crazy
I mean that's basic you don't get people
saying that you know they're in favor
about timers disease or that they want
other people to get outside as disease
this just doesn't happen right and
people that people are perfectly willing
you know with a straight play to say yes
all significant or medicine that
eliminates sickness is good but then
when you point out that there's going to
be the side effect because no signatures
the main thing with people dial and
therefore if you would do significant or
people um you know when you point that
out they suddenly go all like no they
flip and they say oh dear that will be
classic that would be a catastrophe and
they just can't see the cognitive
dissonance so I have to ask myself you
know what is the psychological barrier
here and to me it's all about the fear
of getting ones hopes up people know
that we are we've had aging since the
dawn of civilization we've been
petrified of it because it's so terrible
and yet has been absolutely nothing we
could do about it
moreover there have been people
throughout the history of civilization
who have claimed that there is something
we can do about it and of course they've
never been correct and so there's a lot
of caution with regard to either
believing that this time we are actually
going to get there and also of course
there's believing that it's going to be
in times a year so people just prefer to
carry on believing that the whole thing
is science fiction and coming up with
these crazy irrational means of
perceiving the question out of their
minds you know trying trying to you know
rationalized aging away and pretend that
it's some kind of blessing in disguise
it's really painful and historically it
is it with a sensible thing to do to put
the idea out of your mind because it's
Garf slipping and yet it's inevitable
and so you know you've got to get on
with your miserably short life and make
the best of it but now that we are
within striking distance of bringing
aging under medical control this
attitude it exceeds part of the problem
it is B major reason what's so difficult
to bring
to actually get the research done as
quickly as possible inside of me life is
possible
well along those lines you and I have
spoken a little bit about risk aversion
and if we imagine that humans had the
possibility to live just for the sake of
putting a number on it five hundred
years instead of our current life
expectancy would we not become
incredibly risk-averse where if you I
don't know if you bungee jump at age 50
now you sort of know if it goes wrong
here's how many potential years of life
I'm likely putting it at risk if you
could live five hundred years you're all
of a sudden risking way more life by
bungee jumping at 50 this applies to
driving this applies to whatever
activity we're talking about what's your
sense of that problem it's actually the
only problem or alleged problem for the
elimination of aging that I ever took
seriously when I first started getting
this whole thing let's say twenty years
ago I thought about the risk aversion
issue and I thought yeah you know really
this is actually potentially quite an
issue but quite rapidly I realized that
no it's not an issue because the very
simple because the very simple thing
when something is risky and we actually
care about that risk we have two options
one is not to do the thing that's risky
whether it's you know crossing the
street or whatever that and the other
thing is to make the thing less risky
and of course that's exactly what we're
doing the development of self-driving
cars for example the main driver of that
the people always talk about Isabella
there will be faster your accident quite
apart from the fact that it will also
save a huge amount of money and the same
applies across the board you know we
would put a lot more money into vaccine
development to prevent and death before
they start we would put a lot more money
into searching for asteroids saying that
oh they wouldn't hit the planet you know
things like that and I think that's a
perfectly reasonable thing to expect
that we would simply as our as a in risk
of death from these things is elevated
by default by the elimination of today's
number-one killer we would pay that much
more attention and throw that much more
effort at it now of course what this
does not
dress is a small minority of things that
people like to do specifically because
they are risky you know some people just
like risk and I can do about that but
you know it's a trade off we've been
speaking with dr. Aubrey de Grey the
chief science officer of the Sens
Research Foundation it's always so great
to hear about the work that you're doing
well thank you very much